the speed of light is meant to be the
ultimate speed limit in the universe
according to Einstein's special theory
of relativity
nothing should move through space faster
than light but that doesn't stop people
from trying everyday I get a lot of
messages proposing ways to go faster
than the speed of light there is the
classic method where you shine a laser
at the moon if you can flick that beam
across the moon's surface in less than a
hundredth of a second which is not hard
to do then that laser spot will actually
move across the surface of the Moon
faster than the speed of light imagine
what that would look like if you were
standing on the moon if you were quick
enough to perceive it you would see this
laser spot move faster than the light
coming out of your own laser how is that
even possible well in truth nothing here
is really traveling faster than the
speed of light the individual particles
of light the photons coming out of my
laser are still traveling to the moon at
the speed of light it's just that
they're landing side by side in such
quick succession that they form a spot
which moves faster than the speed of
light but really it's an illusion
nothing is actually going faster than
the speed of light so you couldn't
transmit any information this way dan
asked what if instead of a laser we used
a long rigid stick instead now surely if
you flick your wrist the tip of this
stick must move across the surface of
the moon faster than the speed of light
well unfortunately this won't work
either as we learned in the slinky drop
experiment the fastest of force can
propagate through an object as the speed
of sound that's because each atom needs
to bump into the one next to it to
transmit that force and this is a lossy
process so you'd be lucky if any of the
energy you put in at the start actually
made it to the tip you'd be lucky if the
tip moved at all
now this is a really sophisticated idea
Gerrard writes a very special space-age
engine would need to be designed that is
capable of doing 10,000 plus rpm in
outer space with very high torque
consult Elon Musk for this as the engine
is spinning it slowly deploys two very
long tethers made from carbon nanotubes
on opposing sides eventually each carbon
nanotube tether reaches an amazing
length of 285 kilometers at this point
the end of the tether will be traveling
at the speed of light can you point out
some reasons as to why it would not work
yes Gerard yes I can
first any object going in a sort
go requires a force pulling it in
towards the middle of that circle that's
called centripetal force and you can
feel it when you were a ball above your
head now that force is dependent on the
speed of the object squared so if that
gets to be too great the tether breaks
now if you had a single gram rotating at
99% the speed of light the amount of
force required to pull it towards the
center would be 300 mega Newtons that is
the weight of six thousand fully grown
African elephants but you're right
carbon nanotubes are tremendously strong
if you had a five or just eight
centimeters wide you could support all
of that force but now the problem is if
you have less than a centimeter of that
fiber it adds another gram to the tip of
your tether and so now you need a
thicker fiber in order to support that
additional force and that would happen
all the way to the base the fiber would
need to get thicker and thicker and
thicker all the way back to the motor
and if you do the calculation you find
that basically thirty meters from the
tip the fiber already has to be as wide
as the observable universe in order to
support all of that force it's nuts
but it gets worse as an object moves
faster it's inertia actually increases
that means it requires more force to
accelerate it in fact that one gram mass
going 99% the speed of light would
require seven times the amount of force
we calculated before and so the tether
would have to be even thicker but things
get even more problematic if you think
about speeding up the tip of the tether
that extra 1% to the speed of light I
mean since the inertia keeps getting
greater and greater it requires more and
more force to accelerate it and in fact
to speed it up that extra a little bit
to go the speed of light would require
an infinite amount of energy okay well
putting the infinite energy aside let's
say we could create an incredible motor
and we could find a material much
stronger and lighter than carbon
nanotubes is it at least in principle
possible that the tip could go faster
than light no there is one final problem
which is insurmountable which is that a
tether like anything is held together by
the electromagnetic interaction that is
the attractions between all the tiny
little charges that make up the material
now the problem is electromagnetism is a
force carried by photons I mean the way
that some
knows that another thing is there to
attract it is by the exchange of photons
these force carrying particles the
problem is the photons themselves move
at the speed of light so even if you
could create this incredible apparatus
with ridiculously strong materials and
spin it up with infinite energy it still
wouldn't go the speed of light because
the force carrying particles that hold
the whole thing together only go the
speed of light the speed of light really
is the ultimate speed limit in the
universe hey did you see I made a video
about the problem with Facebook over on
my second channel really seems to have
struck a chord so you should check it
out if you haven't already now I want to
thank audible for supporting this
episode of veritasium they are a leading
provider of audiobooks with over 150,000
titles in all areas of literature from
fiction to nonfiction and periodicals
now this week I wanted to recommend the
book by Bill Bryson called a brief
history of nearly everything when this
book first came out I really wanted to
dislike it because I felt like it was
just piggybacking on Stephen Hawking's
brief history of time but what Bill
Bryson has done is something truly
different and extraordinary I really
think it's a great summary and a great
sort of investigation of what happens in
science it is a brilliant thing to
listen to also if you go to
audible.com/veritasium you can download
this book for free or another of your
choosing now they actually have this
book in an abridged form read by Bill
Bryson himself it's really interesting
to hear the author's voice to me he
sounds a little bit like CGP grey but
with a hint of a British accent so you
should really check that out just go to
audible.com slash veritasium alright
thanks for watching and thanks to
audible for supporting me but there are
some things which are going faster than
the speed of light relative to us
there's some distant galaxies which are
receding at a velocity faster than the
light so we will never be able to see
the light that they emit but this
doesn't violate Einstein's theory of
relativity because they're not moving
through space faster than light it's
just that the space between us and them
is expanding so quickly that their
effective velocity is greater than the
speed of light
you